>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
THANKS.
JOINING US NOW, DR. DEBORAH BIRX
OF THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
DOCTOR, WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
>> Dr. Birx: THANK YOU.
>> Chris: A MONTH AGO, YOU AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP WERE BOTH
TALKING ABOUT A TOTAL OF 60,000
COVID-19 DEATHS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE WE WILL BE AT
ABOUT A 60,000 MARK, WHICH IS
40,000 LESS THAN THE LOWEST
NUMBER THOUGHT OF.
>> LOOK AT HOW MUCH THE MODEL
HAS CHANGED IN JUST A WEEK.
A MEMBER JUST A WEEK AGO IT WAS
80,000.
NOW IT’S 60,000.
>> Chris: EARLY THIS COMING
WEEK WE’RE GOING TO TO REACH
100,000 DEATHS FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS AND THOSE MODELS
THAT YOU’RE CITING NOW TALK
ABOUT CLOSE TO 150,000 DEATHS BY
AUGUST.
WHAT HAPPENED, DR. ?
>> Dr. Birx: I THINK A FEW
THINGS ARE TOGETHER.
SO FROM THE BEGINNING, AND I
THINK WHEN WE HAD THAT FIRST
BRIEFING WE TALKED ABOUT
1.2 MILLION-2.4100240000 MILLION
PEOPLE SUCCUMBING TO THIS
INCREDIBLY AGGRESSIVE VIRUS.
THOSE OTHER FIGURES THAT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO STAND BY IN THIS
FIRST WAVE AND REALLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO PROFESS
FUTURE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
FUTURE DEATHS IS REALLY WHAT
WE’RE FOCUSED FOCUSED ON EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
>> Chris: BUT TO PRESS IT A
LITTLE BIT, A MONTH AGO, YOU ARE
SAYING WE WERE GOING TO COME
DOWN BELOW THE LOW END OF THE
MODEL, WHICH IS 100-240,000,
260,000, SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS, IN THIS LAST MONTH, DID YOU
UNDERESTIMATE THE STRENGTH OF
THE VIRUS, DID WE REOPEN TOO
SOON, DID WE REOPEN WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT RESTRICTIONS?
>> Dr. Birx: WHAT I WAS SAYING
IN THAT BRIEFING THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT IS WHAT THAT
CURRENT MODEL WAS SHOWING.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT MODELS WE
HAVE BEEN USING ALL ALONG AND
REALLY TRYING TO LEARN
PRIMARILY, NOT JUST FOR MODELS,
BUT UNDERSTANDING WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN SPAIN AND ITALY AND
THE U.K. AND REALLY TRACKING
THOSE NUMBERS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT OUR MORTALITY
RATES ARE LESS THAN THOSE THREE
COUNTRIES AND THAT’S REALLY DUE
TO THE INCREDIBLE WORK OF OUR
FRONT-LINE HOSPITAL WORKERS, BUT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THESE NUMBER
OF INFECTIONS HAS LED TO THIS
LEVEL OF MORTALITY AND OUR JOB
NOW GOING FORWARD IS TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREVENT
ADDITIONAL HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
ADDITIONAL MORTALITY.
>> Chris: LET ME PICK UP ON
THAT, DOCTOR, BECAUSE THIS IS,
AS WE SAID, MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND
WHEN PEOPLE ARE GOING OUT MORE
IN PUBLIC, A LOT OF THEM ARE
GOING TO BEACHES, WE ARE RUNNING
VIDEO HERE, SOME PEOPLE ARE
SOCIAL DISTANCING BUT THE
PICTURE YOU PROBABLY CAN’T SEE
ON THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW IN
VENICE BEACH CALIFORNIA, BIG
CROWDS OF PEOPLE, SOME OF THEM
CLOSE TOGETHER.
NOT WEARING MASKS.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU BY SOME OF
WHAT YOU’RE SEEING AROUND THE
COUNTRY THIS MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND?
>> Dr. Birx: WELL, YOU KNOW,
LAST TIME WE SPOKE I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER WITHOUT MASKS EVEN
DURING THE PROTESTS AND NOW I’M
VERY CONCERNED WHEN PEOPLE GO
OUT AND DON’T MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
WHAT DO WE KNOW THAT HAS
CHANGED?
WHEN I HAVE EXCELLENT EVIDENCE
OF HOW FAR DROPLETS GO WHEN WE
SPEAK OR JUST SIMPLY TALKING TO
ONE ANOTHER AND WE KNOW THAT
IT’S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
SOCIALLY INTERACT, BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT’S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE MASKS ON IF WE ARE
LESS THAN 6 FEET AND THAT WE
HAVE TO MAINTAIN THAT 6 FEET
DISTANCE.
WE KNOW BEING OUTSIDE DOES HELP.
IF WE SON DOES HELP IN KILLING
THE VIRUS, BUT THAT DOESN’T
CHANGE THE FACT THAT PEOPLE NEED
TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND MAINTAIN
THAT DISTANCE.
WE KNOW YOU’RE TALKING TO THE
GOVERNOR FROM ARKANSAS, HE’S
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
SUPER-SPREADER EVENTS WHEN
PEOPLE COME TOGETHER BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THIS VIRUS AND
BECAUSE OF ASYMPTOMATIC SPREAD.
AND PEOPLE AREN’T INTENTIONALLY
SPREADING THE VIRUS.
THEY DON’T KNOW THEY’RE
INFECTED, BUT THEY COME TOGETHER
AND THERE UNDER THAT 6 FEET AND
EVERYBODY WHO GETS EXPOSED TO
THAT PERSON LESS THAN 6 FEET HAS
A CHANCE OF BECOMING INFECTED.
>> Chris: SO, DO YOU THINK
SOME OF THIS CROWD OF PEOPLE AT
BEACHES THIS MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND, IS THAT A
SUPER-SPREADER EVENT?
>> Dr. Birx: WELL, FRIDAY WHEN
I DISCUSSED THIS DURING THE
PRESS BRIEFING I WAS REALLY
HOPING TO CONVEY THAT VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE WANT YOU TO BE OUTSIDE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE WAYS THAT
YOU CAN EVEN PLAY TENNIS WITH
MARK’S BALLS SO YOU’RE NOT
TOUCHING EACH OTHER’S BALLS.
WE KNOW THERE IS A WAY FOR YOU
TO GO OUT AND GOLF TUESDAY
DISTANCE.
TO HIKE, TO BE OUTSIDE IN
NATURE, TO BE AT THE BEACH BUT
WILLEY WITHIN THAT IS THE
ABSOLUTE REQUIREMENT THAT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WE KNOW THERE IS
STILL VIRUS OUT THERE AND WE SEE
WHAT WORKPLACES ARE DOING TO
MAKE IT SAFE.
WE SEE WHAT NURSING HOMES ARE
DOING TO TRY TO MAKE IT SAFER
FOR THE RESIDENTS.
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO MAKE IT SAFER
OTHERS IN PUBLIC.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
ON FRIDAY THAT HE IS NOW
DECLARING THAT HOUSES OF WORSHIP
ARE PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES
AND HE WANTS GOVERNORS TO OPEN
HOUSES OF WORSHIP RIGHT AWAY,
TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF THEY DON’T DO IT, I WILL
OVERRIDE THE GOVERNORS.
IN AMERICA WE NEED MORE PRAYER,
NOT LESS.
>> Chris: BUT AS YOU KNOW,
THERE HAVE BEEN A FEW CASES --
NOT WIDESPREAD, BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN A FEW CASES, ONE IN
ARKANSAS, SOME IN CALIFORNIA OR
PEOPLE, SOME OF THEM
ASYMPTOMATIC WITH COVID-19 GO TO
HOUSES OF WORSHIP AND SPREAD AND
THERE ARE MORE INFECTIONS AND IN
SOME CASES EVEN DEATH.
IS IT SAFE TO OPEN ALL HOUSES OF
WORSHIP ACROSS THE COUNTRY TODAY
TODAY?
>> Dr. Birx: I THINK TWO
THINGS HAPPENED ON FRIDAY.
THE PRESIDENT ASKED FOR THE CDC
TO MAKE SURE THERE WERE
GUIDELINES POSTED TO MAKE IT
CLEAR OF HOW CHURCHES COULD OPEN
SAFELY.
AND DURING THAT AND THE
BRIEFING, I MADE IT CLEAR THAT
IT’S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
GOVERNORS AND COMMUNITIES TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW WHERE THERE IS STILL
HIGH LEVELS OF VIRUS.
LIKE IT IS HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., IN CHICAGO AND
IN L.A.
AND TO REALLY ENSURE THAT THOSE
WITH VULNERABILITIES ARE
PROTECTED.
SO ALTHOUGH IT MAY BE SAFE FOR
SOME TO GO TO CHURCHES AND
SOCIAL DISTANCE, IT MAY NOT BE
SAFE FOR THOSE WITH PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, AND THAT’S WHY IN
PHASE ONE AND PHASE TWO, WITH
ASK FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITH
VULNERABILITIES TO REALLY ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE PROTECTED AND
SHELTERING IN PLACE WHILE WE
OPEN UP AMERICA.
>> Chris: THEN THERE ARE THE
ISSUE OF MASKS, WHICH WE TOUCHED
ON BEFORE AND WE ARE SEEING
GROWING CONFRONTATIONS.
FOR INSTANCE, IN STORES WHERE
CUSTOMERS SAY YOU’VE GOT TO WEAR
A MASK AND SOME CUSTOMERS SAY
YOU ARE VIOLATING MY RIGHTS.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
>> I’M ASKING THIS MEMBER TO PUT
ON A MASK BECAUSE THAT IS OUR
COMPANY POLICY.
EITHER WEAR THE MASK.
>> I’M NOT DOING IT BECAUSE I
WOKE UP IN A FREE COUNTRY.
>> Chris: I’M ASKING YOU A
PUBLIC HEALTH QUESTION, NOT A
LEGAL QUESTION.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL SOMEONE WHO
SAYS I HAVE A RIGHT NOT TO WEAR
A MASK IN PUBLIC?
>> Dr. Birx: WELL, WE HAVE
SAID TO PEOPLE, THIS CLEAR
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE NOW BY ALL
THE DROPLET EXPERIMENTS THAT
HAPPENED AND THAT OTHERS HAVE
DONE TO SHOW THAT A MASK DOES
PREVENT DROPLETS FROM REACHING
OTHERS.
AND OUT OF RESPECT FOR EACH
OTHER, AS AMERICANS THAT CARE
FOR EACH OTHER, WE NEED TO BE
WEARING MASKS IN PUBLIC WHEN WE
CANNOT SOCIAL DISTANCE.
IT’S REALLY CLINICALLY CRITICALL
IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE THE SCIENCE OF HOW
IMPORTANT MASK-WEARING IS TO
PRESENT THOSE DROPLETS --
PREVENT THOSE RIGHT DROPLETS
FROM REACHING OTHERS.
>> Chris: DO YOU WISH -- I
WONDER STAN IT’S A SPECIAL
CASE -- I UNDERSTAND IT’S A
SPECIAL CASE, EVERYONE AROUND
THEM IS BEEN TESTED AND
OBVIOUSLY HE IS ON TELEVISION
BUT BOTH FROM A SAFETY POINT OF
VIEW AND FROM A PUBLIC MESSAGING
POINT OF VIEW, DO YOU WISH THE
PRESIDENT WORE A MASK IN PUBLIC?
>> Dr. Birx: WELL, THE
PRESIDENT DID WEAR A MASK WHILE
HE WAS LESS THAN 6 FEET IN AN
OCCASION WHERE THAT WAS
IMPORTANT OVER I THINK WHEN HE
WAS TRAVELING LAST WEEK.
I THINK HE -- WITH HIM -- ARE
NOT WITH HIM EVERY DAY AND EVERY
MOMENT SO I DON’T KNOW IF HE CAN
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCE.
I’VE ASKED EVERYBODY
INDEPENDENTLY TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT YOU’RE WEARING A MASK
IF YOU CAN’T MAINTAIN THE
6 FEET.
I’M ASSUMING THAT A MAJORITY OF
CASES HE’S ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
6 FEET DISTANCE.
>> Chris: FINALLY, THERE WERE
SOME PROMISING REPORTS THAT THIS
WEEK ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT GET A
VACCINE SOONER THAN WE EXPECTED.
HERE’S THE PRESIDENT ON THAT
THIS WEEK.
>> WE ARE LOOKING TO -- WHEN I
SAY QUICKLY, WE’RE LOOKING TO
GET IT BY THE END OF THE YEAR IF
WE CAN.
MAYBE BEFORE.
WE ARE DOING TREMENDOUSLY WELL.
>> Chris: A MONTH AGO, YOU AND
DR. FAUCI WERE BOTH TALKING
ABOUT TAKING 12 TO 18 MONTHS TO
GET A VACCINE.
NOW YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
POSSIBLY BY THE END OF THE YEAR,
WHICH WOULD CUT THAT TIMELINE IN
HALF.
I UNDERSTAND EVERYBODY WANTS IT.
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT WE ARE
GOING TO SEE A VACCINE READILY
AVAILABLE BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR?
>> Dr. Birx: I THINK WHAT
WOULD MAKE IT POTENTIALLY
POSSIBLE IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS ASKED EVERYONE TO DO IN THIS
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WITH
FUNDING DIRECTLY TO MAKE THAT
VACCINE AT RISK, AND WHAT
REMAINED BY THAT?
THAT MEANS MAKING VACCINE BEFORE
WE KNOW IT’S FULL SAFETY IN FULL
EFFECT AND WHAT WE CALL ITS
EFFICACY PROFILE.
TO MAKE VACCINES STARTING NOW AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO WHEN
THERE IS THAT EFFICACY AND
SAFETY SIGNAL -- SO WE’RE NOT
SURE CUTTING THE EFFICACY AND
SAFETY TESTING, WHAT WE ARE
SHORTCUTTING IS THE NORMAL
DEVELOPMENT TIME OF
MANUFACTURING, AND SOBERLY
STARTING MANUFACTURING WHAT
WOULD BE SIX MONTHS EARLIER
SEVEN MONTHS EARLY.
THAT’S HOW YOU COULD POTENTIALLY
SHORTEN THIS BY 4-6 OR EVEN
EIGHT MONTHS.
AND THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW,
TAKING THE MOST PROMISING
CANDIDATES AND GETTING THEM INTO
MANUFACTURING, ENSURING THAT YOU
CAN SCALE AND PRODUCE THESE
VACCINES AT THE LEVEL THAT IS
NEEDED FOR AMERICANS.
>> Chris: WELL, WE ALL HOPE